le 10 octobre 1979 commence une affaire
qui va empoisonner le septennat de
valéry giscard d'estaing le scandale des
diamants de bokassa un cadeau
présidentiel qui va vite se transformer
en cadeau empoisonné
monsieur giscard d'estaing at il été en
possession de ce cadeau présidentiel et
dans ce cas est il resté en possession
de ce cadeau l'affairé révélée par le
canard enchaîné en 1973 alors que valéry
giscard d'estaing était ministre des
finances il a reçu en cadeau de la part
de l' empereur de centrafrique des
plaquettes de diamant le journal
satirique les estime à 150 mille euros
le scandale est repris dans toutes les
rédactions mais certains journalistes il
voit une manigances politiciennes
cette affaire a évidemment une
signification politique
elle vise à discréditer le président de
la république au moment où l'on commence
tout le monde le sait à se préoccuper de
la future élection présidentielle
du côté de l'opposition on reproche au
président son silence
mais surtout la pression qu'il mettrait
sur les rédactions pour étouffer la
sphère très peu de couvertures à la
télévision publique revisitée censurer
toute la france vous interroge c'est
vrai où ces fonds
les diamants giscard dix ans si c'est ça
qu'on le dise nettement si c'est vrai
bien cherche est embarrassant mais le
président refuse de répondre
et ce silence qui ressemble à du mépris
ne fait qu'empirer la situation
finalement plus d'un mois plus tard le
27 novembre 1979
valéry giscard d'estaing s'explique face
aux caméras et je vous cache pas que
c'est désobligeant pour moi de répondre
à des questions de cette nature mais je
peux vous dire que déjà cours des
dernières années de nombreux cadeaux ont
été envoyés à des oeuvres de
bienfaisance et enfin à la question est
posée sur la valeurs de toujours et reçu
comme ministre des finances
j'oppose un démenti catégorique et
j'ajoute méprisant
des explications qui ne sont pas
satisfaisantes pour son futur adversaire
politique françois mitterrand tout homme
public y compris bien entendu le plus
important d'entre eux doit être en
mesure à tout moment d'expliquer et de
s'expliquer sans que l'on préjuge en
quoi que ce soit approbation
condamnation jusqu'à la veille de
l'élection présidentielle de 1981
cette affaire des diamants poursuivra
valéry giscard d'estaing
c'est ça l'idée c'était de make-up
c'était mal me connaître
au moment du scandale aucune commission
d' enquête parlementaire ne sera montée
est encore aujourd'hui
aucune estimation objectifs des diamants
n'a été réalisée
[Musique]